[Musique]
l'hôpital public en france hyper délit
il a perdu délit
historiquement pour des raisons
budgétaires il ya des fermetures de lits
mais ce qui est nouveau c'est que depuis
un deux ans il perd des lits parce que
les personnels soignants s'en vont et on
compte par milliers les infirmières et
les aides-soignantes qui ont quitté
l'hopital public depuis la crise
sanitaire entraînant donc des fermetures
de lits
d'emblée nous avons souhaité entendre
les les acteurs de terrain les soignants
nous avons entendu également les
fédérations hospitalières
qu'elles soient publiques privées l'a
fait happer également uni cancer pour
avoir le regard en effet sur la
situation actuelle nous voulons d'abord
avoir une connaissance réelle de ce qui
se passe sur le terrain nous
interrogeons bien sûr aussi par des
contributions écrites mais c'est d'abord
une vision en effet qu'est ce qui se
passe au niveau de l'hôpital et là on se
rend compte que la situation
catastrophique
les soignants nous disent nous
comprenons plus ce qu'on nous demande
quand une infirmière devait s'occuper
auparavant de 10 patients elle en a
maintenant 15 en charge et de ce fait
elle ne consacrent plus suffisamment de
temps patients elle a le sentiment de
mal faire son travail d'être
maltraitante et c'est pour ça qu'elle
quitte l'hôpital et donc je crois que la
commission denquête sera utile notamment
si elle permet de proposer des solutions
et des solutions rapides à cette crise
du sens des soignants
la crise sanitaire a mis en exergue les
difficultés de l'hôpital elle était pré
existante à la craie sanitaires elles ne
sont pas que le fait de ce gouvernement
nous allons aussi faire une analyse des
lois
qui travaillent qui organise les soins
organise l'hôpital s'était notamment la
loi hpst de madame bachelot il est
ensuite la loi touraine la loi de madame
buza nous allons faire tout un bilan
voir ce qui a bien marché voir ce qui en
revanche a eu des effets négatifs mais
la situation pour exister bien avant la
crise sanitaire
la commission denquête un avantage c'est
d'abord que symboliquement elle dit
l'importance que l'on attache au sujet
est par ailleurs la commission denquête
pour les personnes qu'on entend est
aussi un message qu'il aurait envoyé de
l'importance de leur témoignage devant
la commission denquête nous ne cherchons
pas à mettre en évidence des faits qui
seraient d'ordre on va dire délictuelle
comme une commission denquête en avoir
le pouvoir ce n'est pas l'objet l'objet
là je crois c'est vraiment de porter au
premier plan la question de l'hôpital
est de pouvoir proposer des solutions
applicables rapidement